[Music]
the Confederation Congress was not the
only government in America with money
problems port for that matter even the
worst problems that the Congress had no
practical way of dealing with those woes
was bad but the states didn't have the
means to deal with their money problems
either and the decisions they made about
those problems almost make the paralysis
of the Confederation Congress look
appealing these problems appeared almost
as soon as the revolution had begun in
the spring of 1775 as soon as the news
of Lexington and Concord and then Bunker
Hill arrived in Philadelphia the
Pennsylvania assembly began purchasing
firearms and stores and established a 25
member committee of safety to oversee
the purchases Benjamin Franklin was
named the committee's chair but the real
leadership of the committee fell to a
Philadelphia merchant Robert Morris
partner in the substantial Philadelphia
trading firm of willing Morris and with
good reason since no one knew what the
cost of the conflict with Britain might
be and the Pennsylvania Treasury was
until new tax measures were passed and
funds collected wholly inadequate to the
first demands made on it taxation
requires time in all governments Morris
remarked America cannot suddenly be
therefore brought to pay all which might
be spared from the wealth of our
citizens so Morris obligingly advanced
the whopping sum of 25 thousand pounds
from his own purse given that gunpowder
was selling on foreign markets at 14
pounds to 19 pounds a barrel this would
not last long and it didn't but when the
assembly turned to consider raising new
funds through tax revenues they
encountered the unpleasant legacy of all
of the British colonies as they had
inherited the problems from British
policy over the previous quarter century
the fundamental problem was that
America's most abundant asset was
and at its least abundant asset with
specie hard coin now this was in large
measure a product of British commercial
regulation Britain's transatlantic
commercial philosophy was built around
mercantilism as defined by treatises
from Thomas MUNs 1664 book on England's
treasure by foreign trade - Sir James
Stewart's and inquiry into the
principles of political economy of 1767
mercantilism assumed that national
wealth was a zero-sum game every nation
started out with a piece of the pie of
wealth and could only become richer by
taking pieces of other people's slices
that means that for doing so there were
three possibilities three strategies to
be pursued
first of all create financial reserves
of hard coin real money wrote Sir James
Stewart is what we call coin under the
authority of a state regulate the
nation's economy to produce goods that
other countries will pay hard coin for
and subsidize the development of
production which will allow your people
to buy domestically produced goods they
would otherwise have bought from other
countries either through direct cash
subventions or by imposing high tariffs
and prevent one's reserves of coin from
flowing easily into the hands of other
countries that meant that governments
must organize economies just as they
organize politics as weapons of war with
other governments rather than simply
letting economies take their own course
so James Stewart said from reason it is
plain that industry must give wealth and
wealth will give power if he who
possesses it be left the master to
employ it as he pleases a government
could not therefore encourage a system
which tended to throw power into the
hands of the
those who were only made to obey
therefore Stuart urged we must encourage
economy frugality and a simplicity of
manners discourage the consumption of
everything that can be sold out of the
country and excite a taste for
superfluity in neighboring countries
establish colonies in places with
valuable resources you can extract
that's the third strategy making sure
that those colonies are also regulated
so that their trade is carried in your
ships and send supplies of hard coin
home to benefit your treasury the
statesman Stuart declared will buy
subsistence for the surplus of his
people by establishing colonies and thus
while all his subjects are employed and
provided for he will remain at the head
of a flourishing and happy people
Britain by this means starve its
colonies of specie every piece of
British commercial legislation from 1660
onwards reach deeper and deeper into the
colonial economies to ensure that the
colonies served Britain's economic
interests the colonies got by for
themselves by issuing paper currency and
IOUs in the form of tax anticipation
notes and land banks which lent money to
farmers for improvements and taking
their existing land as collateral but
Parliament forbade the creation of
corporations or banks and the colonies
so there was no mechanism for
accumulating significant reserves from
what small amounts of specie came into
American hands and some specie did come
to Americans Spanish dollars Dutch
guilders French lui door and largely
through selling goods to the French West
Indies the Spanish Caribbean and the
Dutch but it flowed out just as quickly
since Britain demanded payment in specie
whenever it was available for merchants
like Morris
business transactions were handled
through loans or privately written IOUs
known as bills of credit or Bills of
exchange by the outbreak of the
revolution three-quarters of all the
money circulating in the colonies was
paper of various sorts the sudden demand
for financing the revolution caught both
the Congress and the states ill-equipped
to meet the unprecedented demands of
paying for war and in the cases of both
Congress and the states the most
familiar expedient and the one which
involved the least political courage was
the issue of massive amounts of paper
currency by the end of the Revolution
seven of the 13 states had authorized
the emission of paper money Pennsylvania
for instance issued 100,000 pounds in
paper money backed by the proceeds of
the sale of public land in Philadelphia
nor did it stop with the end of the war
in 1785 South Carolina used a land bank
system to issue 100,000 pounds in paper
money
Georgia follow a year later with the
issue of fifty thousand pounds and state
money
supposedly secured by lands which were
actually owned by the Creek Indians the
state money was supposed to finance a
war against the creeks which would then
seize the land after a year the lands
remained in creeks and and the Georgia
money had fallen to 1/4 of its face
value North Carolina authorized the
issue of one hundred thousand pounds in
paper money which the legislature used
to buy up the state's tobacco crop and
thus benefit the farmers who got paid
for their tobacco and also benefit the
state of North Carolina since the
tobacco could then be sold abroad for a
tidy profit alas for North Carolina the
price of tobacco abroad fell and the
North Carolina currency fell to such
miserable levels that merchants refused
to accept it Pennsylvania
followed with the printing of another
150,000 pounds in paper New York up to
the ante by printing two hundred
thousand pounds
the most notorious however was Rhode
Island which issued one hundred thousand
pounds in paper money in May 1786 and
then attached to it a requirement that
it be received by merchants and lenders
as a legal tender in payment of all
contracts and a refusal to receive them
cancelled the debt so while the
Confederation Congress limped by on
grudging foreign loans and equally
grudging contributions from the states
the states themselves felt perfectly
free to print their own money and what
made this all the more dangerous was
when farmers and small-scale borrowers
discovered that this was not only an
easy way to pay their state's war debts
but a painless way to make their own
commercial debts disappear loans and
mortgages which have been contracted
before the Revolution could now be
effortlessly paid off in cheap paper
currency and if lenders and Merchants
balked at accepting the paper money or
refused to take it
unless of a substantial discount from
face value the legislators like Rhode
Island's can always pass penalty laws
which criminalized such refusals the
paper money of this state has run down
to six for one complained one Providence
Rhode Island merchants notwithstanding
which the legislature continued it as a
tender and mean to do so and pay off all
the state debts with it be it as bad as
it may a more infamous set of men under
the character of a legislature never I
believe disgrace the annals of the world
and there is no prospect for any change
for the better but Rhode Island or Rhode
Island as it was nicknamed was only the
most notorious for compelling the
acceptance of what became little more
than paper itself South Carolina backed
up its paper money with a pine barren
Act which forced lenders to accept
repayment in real estate which would be
a small use to a merchant in Charleston
who had vendors to satisfy in Lisbon or
Amsterdam the depreciating paper
currency also created a problem between
states when merchants in Massachusetts
or Connecticut demanded payment for
goods sold in Rhode Island and were
presented with paper currency they knew
was worthless anyplace except Rhode
Island there was nothing the Rhode
Island legislature could do to reach
across state boundaries and compel them
to accept Rhode Island paper but the
legislature did almost as much by
permitting Rhode Islanders to pay the
amounts owed in Rhode Island currency to
the Rhode Island Courts which then
declared the out-of-state debts
legally satisfied this of course
triggered an uproar in the Confederation
Congress the North Carolinian Richard
Speight wrote anxiously that the General
Assembly of Connecticut have reprobated
in very severe terms the conduct of the
state of Rhode Island and have
ultimately come to a determination to
remonstrate to Congress against the
injustice of the proceedings of Rhode
Island I should not be surprised if they
were to compel them by force to do
justice to their citizens citizens of
Connecticut it seems their laws enable
them to pay the citizens of any other
state off with their paper money which
is depreciated to eight or nine for one
but do not allow the citizens of any
other state to pay them off with it
their mode of process is that any
citizen of Rhode Island who is indebted
to the citizen of any other state or a
foreigner may go and lodge the debt in
paper money in the hands of any
magistrate who gives them a discharge
for the same and advertises the payment
that the creditor may come in and take
his money which if he does not do in a
certain limited time the law requires
that it should be paid into the public
treasury for the benefit of the state
in Massachusetts anger boiled even
higher Massachusetts Judge Francis Dana
hoped that some bold politician would
seize upon the occasion of its
abominations and anti federal conduct
for annihilating Rhode Island as a
separate member of the Union but the
frustration Dana felt over Rhode
Island's behavior had a much more
dangerous political corollary because he
suggested that Republican forms of
government which lodged sovereignty and
the people as a whole which sooner or
later prove that large numbers of those
people were wholly unworthy to exercise
sovereignty that given political power
they would embark on more and more
reckless schemes for defrauding others
while preening themselves as the
tribunes of the nation Nathaniel Gorham
who represented Massachusetts in the
Confederation Congress warned that Rhode
Island showed that public bodies feel no
personal responsibility and give full
play to intrigue and cabal Rhode Island
is a full illustration of the
insensibility to character produced by a
participation of numbers in dishonorable
measures and of the lengths to which a
public body may carry wickedness and
cabal and The Virginian William Grayson
who also sat in the Confederation
Congress complained that the ancients
we're surely men of more candor than we
are they contended openly for an
abolition of debts in so many words
while we strive as hard for the same
thing under the decent and specious
pretence of a circulating medium the
democratical might be as tyrannical as
the despotic for where is there a
greater act of despotism than that of
issuing paper to depreciate for the
purpose of paying debts on easy terms
but in the state legislature these
complain
or dismissed as the whinings of the rich
and the property or worse the diabolical
dispositions of merciless creditors the
times have been such as to render
regulations of this kind necessary and
most or all the states replied one
maryland delegate to prevent the wealthy
creditor and the moneyed man from
totally destroying the poor though even
industrious debtor such times may arrive
again in Philadelphia the Freeman's
Journal indignantly prophesied that
without paper money the people will
shrink in despair from the magnitude and
frequency of the tax bills which they
declare themselves unable to discharge
for want of cash which is not to be
obtained paper money is in fact the
traditional medium of America but true
PAC Tholian stream which converts all
into gold that is washed by it and the
man who was about to be drowned in that
legendary pack Tholian stream with its
Golden Sands was none other than the man
who first offered to finance the
revolution out of his own pocket Robert
Morris Morris was originally from
Liverpool and probably born a legitimate
his father was an agent for a shipping
firm and when the company sent him to
Maryland to oversee their interests he
brought his thirteen-year-old son over
with him and eventually apprenticed the
boy to a merchant in Philadelphia
Charles willing he kept Ledger's
monitored accounts issued bills of
credit and when Charles willing died in
1754 willing son Thomas reorganized the
company to make Morris his partner
Morris rose in wealth and standing
eventually being appointed as a port
warden for Philadelphia and in 1775 was
tagged to represent Pennsylvania in the
Second Continental Congress he was
dubious about the wisdom of Independence
but he signed the Declaration of
Independence anyway and none of his
doubts prevented him from advancing
money from his own pocket
to pay the revolution's bills probably
all told over 1 million pounds or 75% of
the Congress is wartime expenditures not
surprisingly when the Confederation
Congress moved in 1781 to create three
executive offices to maintain its
day-to-day affairs for war Foreign
Affairs and Finance Robert Morris was
unanimously named superintendent of
Finance Morris however had seen enough
of Congress's financial mismanagement to
have still further doubts about the
wisdom of accepting the position and he
did not actually accept the post until
May of 1781 and even then only on the
condition that first he concentrates
solely on a new financial system not the
payment of old debts or the still
accumulating military expenses of the
revolution second that he had full power
to appoint and dismiss all persons
whatever that are concerned in the
official expenditure of public monies
and third that he be permitted to carry
on his own private business affairs at
the same time he achieved a series of
small financial wonders for the
Confederation a new 5.9 million loan
from France another two million dollar
loan from the Dutch but he also made
enemies The Virginian William Lee whose
brother Richard Henry Lee had proposed
the original motion for independence in
1776 denounced Morris as the most
dangerous man in America and accused him
of plunging the United States of America
in public bankruptcy while he at the
same time amassed an immense fortune for
himself in July 1779 a congressional
committee report attacked Morris for
profiteering but even more damning to
Morris's reputation was his opposition
to paper money from 1779 until his
appointment as superintendent of Finance
Morris walked the issue of paper money
in the Pennsylvania Assembly tooth and
nail especially when it was suggested
that Pennsylvania's paper money like
Rhode Island's be declared legal tender
with penalties for non acceptance Morris
insisted that the tender and penal laws
were destructive of all credit and he
wrote to George Washington that he would
press our assembly to levy effective
taxes in hard money but this only made
William Lee indignantly accused Morris
of driving paper money out of
circulation and allowing nothing but
gold and silver to be current so that
Morris could set up a deliberate
financial swindle Morris had amassed
substantial holdings of depreciated
paper currency while it was current at
one thousand and twelve hundred percent
under value and was now said the
accusation trying to secure to himself
the payment of the paper money that he
had collected at a substantial profit
Morris was eventually acquitted of all
charges but not before they had almost
cost him his life on October 4th a
Street mob whipped up by charges that
Morris was at the heart of all their
economic woes attacked Morris James
Wilson George Clymer
and twenty or so others who belonged to
a Republican Society at City Tavern in
Philadelphia Morris and the Society
retreated to Wilson's stout three-story
house at third and Walnut Streets and
when the mob pursued them they
barricaded the doors and shuttered the
windows someone began shooting and in
short order at the mob stormed the house
breaking down the doors and trading
gunfire on the stairs which dropped
several of them the mob
wheeled of a small howitzer but as they
did the first city troop of cavalry
appeared and sabers swinging disperse
the mob the Battle of Fort Wilson
four of the mob dead and 14 wounded no
one could have blamed Morris after the
Battle of Fort Wilson for washing his
hands completely of Public Affairs nor
could anyone in the Congress blame him
for driving a hard bargain over his
powers as superintendent of Finance in
1781 William Livingston the governor of
New Jersey
tried to sue Morris's disgruntlement
with the assurance that you have done
too much for your country not to create
enemies and indeed in these times so
checkered with corruption and patriotism
with public depravity and public virtue
to have no enemies rather diminishes
that increases the luster of one's
character but it was also true that the
Revolution had spawned what one Boston
newspaper complained about as a private
selfish and basely avaricious spirit in
the room of public virtue and it was
difficult for Morris to insist on strict
financial probity when he believed that
American Commerce is so managed as that
it becomes a public nuisance instead of
a common benefit and thousands of widows
orphans and poor people are ground
almost to death by the greediness of
avaricious merchants monopolize errs
farmers sharpers for stallers mushroom
traders all of whom have been and still
are outdoing one another in raising the
price of everything but as clearly as
Morris understood that America's chief
peril lay in the derangement of our
money affairs he could not get the
states or the Confederation Congress to
agree to any solution he proposed on
July 29 1782 Morris submitted to the
Confederation Congress an ambitious plan
for restoring the intimate connection
between the Commerce the agriculture and
the finances of a country first and
foremost was the approval of the 5% in
post passed by Congress in 1781
which was so obvious emotion that this
revenue may be considered as being over
too gained second Marsh recommended a
national property tax on land a large
proportion of America is the property of
great land holders who monopolize it
without cultivation tax those land
holdings and it would both bring in
revenue and stimulate the sale of land
by the great land holders to avoid the
taxes it would relieve the indigent and
aggrandize the state by bringing
property into the hands of those who
would use it for the benefit of society
third Marsh recommended recall of paper
money by exchanging it for a national
loan offered at 4% interest and thus
create a clear certain permanent and
increasing basis for foreign borrowing
fourth establish a Bank of North America
which would use a public charter and
private investment to supply the
necessities of the husbandman as well as
the merchant but Rhode Island sabotage
the impost by folding its arms and
refusing to approve it and a renewed
initiative for the in post in 1784
failed as well the Bank of North America
was chartered by the Confederation
Congress and incorporated by the
Pennsylvania Assembly and began
operations in 1782 backed by the specie
Morris had raised from the French and
Dutch loans but in 1785 Morris's enemies
on the Pennsylvania Assembly engineered
a repeal of the state incorporation of
the Bank and when it was objected that
the assembly ought to at least notify
the Confederation Congress one member
replied we are not bound by any terms
made by Congress Congress are our
creatures Morris damaged his own
standing by egging on the Continental
Army's mutiny in the hope that he could
somehow you
the soldiers threat to beat back his
foes and critics by October of 1783
the Massachusetts legislature was
instructing its delegation to the
Confederation Congress to have the
office of the superintendent of Finance
abolished and a board of Treasury
consisting of three persons and you will
he chosen from different states with
proper powers instituted in instead
disgusted Morris turned in his
resignation and left his post on
November 1st 1784 my attention to the
public debts he explained the president
of Congress Elias Boudinot arose from
the conviction that funding them on
solid revenues was the last essential
work of our glorious revolution but
other circumstances have postponed the
establishment of public credit in such a
manner that I fear it will never be made
and Massachusetts ironically would soon
offer the first proof of Morris's dread